netflix is officially the worst
performing stock in the s p 500 being
down over 60
and that's just since the start of this
year
if we measure from their peak in late
november we'll see that netflix is down
nearly 70 percent this means that you
can get netflix stock right now for the
same price as four years ago and this
also means that netflix has shed an eye
watering at 216.8
billion dollars worth of market cap this
is quite a turn for netflix given that
netflix was the best performing stock of
the last decade growing over four
thousand percent
it certainly didn't anticipate a global
international launch you know all at
once in in 2013. those are the things
that drove the stock higher yet
currently they're on the other end of
the spectrum a few weeks ago i made a
similar video discussing the state of
netflix and at the time they were
already doing quite bad at being down
over 50 percent but they were starting
to make a bit of a recovery and it
seemed like it was just a matter of time
until netflix would recover from the
downtrend ever since netflix announced
that they lost 200 000 subscribers and
warned that more subscriber losses could
be coming in the future things haven't
been looking as optimistic it looks like
this crash may be more of a bubble
popping event as opposed to a simple
market downtrend so is netflix past the
point of recovery
the first thing to note is that we can
no longer just chalk up the selloff to a
market downturn while the market hasn't
been making new all-time highs week
after week like it was last year it's
also not like it's down 40 or 50 percent
the s p 500 is only down 9
and the nasdaq is down 18
such a selloff may lead to a mega cap
like netflix selling off 30 maybe 40
but not 70
just look at tesla for example tesla is
likely the most richly valued growth
stock in the entire market yet they're
only down 19 from their all-time high
because they're still killing it
fundamentally so clearly netflix's
selloff has a lot more to do with
fundamental shortfalls as opposed to
market shortfalls with that being said
the biggest challenge ahead for netflix
is continuing subscriber growth netflix
and a bunch of their investors have been
trying to justify their recent
subscriber loss by blaming it on russia
you see it netflix had to write off 700
000 subscribers due to russian account
suspensions so if we exclude this amount
netflix would have actually gained 500
000 subscribers last quarter but
honestly this doesn't really change
anything even if we give netflix the
benefit and say that the subscribers
grew by half a million last quarter
compared to their 221 million existing
subscribers this growth is absolute
garbage in terms of percentages this
comes out to just a 0.226 growth even if
we extrapolate this growth to an entire
year we don't even get one percent
growth for perspective even mature
companies like apple and google
generally oppose 20 to 30 growth numbers
year after year considering this
netflix's subscriber base is at the very
least stagnating and given that netflix
estimates that they will lose another 2
million subscribers this quarter this
lackluster performance doesn't seem to
be a one-off anomaly either
so what's causing people to leave in
droves well the answer is quite
straightforward the primary reason that
people cancel subscriptions is because
they feel that it's no longer worth it
for the longest time netflix has not
only been losing some of their best
content but they have been constantly
increasing prices netflix currently
charges 9.99 for their basic plan or 120
per year
meanwhile disney plus costs eight
dollars per month and they have an
annual plan that costs 80 per year
so by getting a disney plus subscription
viewers can not only save up to 50 on
subscription fees but they can arguably
get access to better content while
netflix does still have a large lead in
terms of total movies and tv shows
against disney this doesn't really mean
much given that the average person and
doesn't care about the vast majority of
the content on netflix conversely while
disney plus has a smaller catalog
everything they do have is bangers from
star wars to the avengers something else
to note is that it's not like netflix
had to make these price increments
either much of their price increases
over the past 6 years have gone directly
to their bottom line since 2016
netflix's net margin has exploded from
about 2 to 17
and it seems that as netflix's profits
went to parabolic their value
proposition fell off a cliff
while it seems like netflix is just
going to continue losing content to
competitors as production studios open
up their own streaming services there is
some hope for netflix after i posted my
last video on netflix a subscriber
actually reached out to me and let me
know that netflix actually has a lot of
background licensing deals that have yet
to come to fruition for example netflix
apparently has a deal with the disney to
license all of the movies that came out
between january of 2016 and december of
2018. the catch however is that netflix
can't start streaming these movies until
2026 this gives disney four more years
to eat in the netflix's customer base
and given that disney plus already has
129 million subscribers and that disney
plus has only been a thing for a little
more than two years this doesn't bode
well for netflix aside from having
plenty of time to steal customers from
netflix disney will also have eight
years worth of backlog content between
2018 and 2026 that netflix won't have
access to and i doubt that disney will
be making any such deals with netflix
moving forward this applies to all the
other production studios as well
while they may be tied up with netflix
for several more years you can bet that
they won't be extending such deals much
further so really the only solution
netflix has for this conundrum is to
make their own content and fortunately
this is exactly what they've been doing
but the problem is that most of their
originals are hit or miss
while you do have some mega hits like
squid game the vast majority of the
original shows don't receive much
fanfare now this isn't exactly netflix's
fault it's simply the nature of the
media business you often have to swing
several times to hit a home run the
problem though is that this process is
not only capital intensive but time
intensive production studios like disney
warner brothers and paramount studios
have literally been swinging for over a
hundred years to produce the classics
that we all know and love today
meanwhile netflix has only been swinging
for 10 years so it's no wonder that
they've been struggling to build up the
catalog that their competitors have
something else to note is that netflix's
streaming model has inadvertently made
it a lot harder for them to retain
customers generally whenever netflix
launches a new season of a show they
post the entire season right away
now i'm a massive fan of this approach
being able to simply press next episode
after a crazy cliffhanger is so nice
but from a business perspective this is
not that great over the years netflix
has created a phenomenon that a lot of
us are extremely familiar with and
that's binging the best bingers amongst
us are usually done with the season by 5
am the next morning but even if you're
not that hardcore you're likely done
within a week with regular tv you would
have had to spend months if not years
watching the same show and the
opportunity to binge has made it
extremely convenient for customers to
buy a netflix subscription for a month
and then instantly cancel and as you
would guess this is not that great for
customer attention or long-term profits
it's no secret that over the years our
attention spans have been continuously
decreasing and the best evidence of this
is the rise of tick tock initially this
was actually one of the main reasons
that netflix even did so well
people didn't have to wait months or
years to watch a show they could binge
it over a few weeks but the problem is
that the average person's patience and
attention span have shrunk even smaller
and netflix has struggled to keep up one
of the worst parts of watching netflix
is trying to find something good often
times you spend 20 to 30 minutes just
going to netflix and looking up reviews
until you finally find something to
watch
meanwhile youtube and tick tock have
perfected their content recommendation
algorithms which gives us an endless
stream of content to watch statistically
speaking 82 percent of you guys didn't
search up this video rather it was
recommended to you only 5.6 percent of
you guys actually looked up this video
and while the youtube search box is
still super helpful if you're trying to
find a tutorial or a review about a
certain product for casual entertainment
refreshing the home page until you find
something good to watch is usually the
way to go with netflix however you can't
really do this and this brings up a
serious question is it actually disney
plus and hulu and paramount plus that
are stealing netflix's watch time or is
it youtube tick tock instagram and
snapchat about 10 years ago we had a
very similar situation with netflix and
traditional tv tv channels were bleeding
watch time at like crazy but it wasn't
other tv channels that were stealing it
from them rather the culprit was netflix
similarly i believe the corporate today
is actually social media after all
tiktok was literally the most visited
site in 2021 so netflix is not only
competing against production companies
but also social media companies and
while netflix may have a chance against
the production companies i'm not as
optimistic when it comes to their
chances against social media
by now i think we've made it pretty
clear that netflix isn't doing that
great fundamentally this isn't to say
that netflix is gonna file for
bankruptcy anytime soon but it does look
like they've hit a local top and the
question is can netflix adapt to
changing times and keep this at a local
top or will this become an absolute top
well to answer this question we can take
a look at historical charts of other
companies that underwent a similar
crisis like microsoft throughout the 80s
and the 90s microsoft crushed it as
personal computer adoption went to the
moon but by the early 2000s microsoft
hit market saturation and this also
coincided with the dot-com crash which
left microsoft devastated during the
dot-com crash microsoft shed a total of
66 percent which is quite similar to
netflix today
the thing to note though is that it took
microsoft 16 years to recover and to
make new all-time highs
now if microsoft had embraced a
smartphone boom i think they could have
made this recovery much sooner maybe in
2009 or 2010 but they didn't and it
wasn't until they embraced the cloud
computing boom that they finally took
off again with netflix i think they're
already quite late to really capitalize
on the social media slash user generated
content boom so like microsoft they're
going to have to turn their attention on
to the next big thing maybe that's vr
and ar content i'm not sure but one
thing i am sure of is that making this a
transition would take quite a bit of
time combine this with the fed
tightening and a great deleveraging
potentially around the corner and the
netflix may not make new all-time highs
for years to come
also let's not forget that there's no
guarantee that netflix must make a new
all-time high in the first place given
their current situation they could
easily end up like cisco or intel
while this video has been quite critical
on netflix i'm still leaning on the side
of betting that netflix will eventually
recover even though they're user counter
stagnating i don't think their
innovative spirit is stagnating and i'm
rather confident that reed hastings will
figure out something by opening up
netflix to a new market with all that
being said though this type of
transition won't take place within a
matter of 6 or 12 months for a mega cab
company like netflix to pivot into new
sectors and make these endeavors
profitable it'll take several years and
in the meantime investing in netflix is
really just a toss-up given how oversold
the stock is we may see a recovery back
up to 400 or 500
on the other hand if the market really
starts to sell off as the fed tightens
there may be a lot more pain to come for
netflix either way though for netflix to
become the fundamental king that they
were in the 2010s i think it's going to
take several years of trial and error
and personally i wouldn't invest here as
capital into the company until they
figure out another mode of growth but
that's just what i think would you guys
invest in netflix comment that down
below
also drop a like if you'd rather watch
youtube than netflix and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hurry and i'll see
you guys on the next one
you